stormzy so good to see you we're in
Dusseldorf how do you feel in Dusseldorf
I'm excited it's nice you know my first
time in not two people I might not be my
first time I'm not saying that I might
have been here before but yeah nice
exciting man you're about to drop a
record really soon what side of stormzy
are we gonna see in this new record
that's a good question I think just well
my soul you're gonna see myself I'm
bearing myself as I always do but I feel
this time you know we'll grow you know
if you learn to Bear it better if that's
even a thing maybe is this your most
personal record ever yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's fair to say yeah what's the
song or the lyric that you're just most
excited for your fans to hear that's
another good question
um I'm just I'm excited for everyone to
hear the whole album in this entirety
and sit down
put your efforts and then listen yeah
man yeah what a treat to see you during
the Adele special headlines everywhere
stormzy might be the biggest Adele fan
in the world tell me about your friend
with her and what makes it so special uh
you know I I as as anyone knows I think
that from
before I even knew her I still have to
stay a massive fan you know I mean and I
think everyone just knows the woman that
they see is as remarkable as she is in
real life as they see on the screen you
know I mean so that's a dear friend of
mine so that cameras aren't rolling what
goes down during a storm
[Music]
conversations that you have with a
friend yeah it's it's nothing um yeah
it's nothing headline grabbing it's just
that's that's my that's my family I love
her so yeah gonna go to Vegas and see
her yeah yeah I'm there next week
[Music]